oh the joy and pain so continuing on
with overdue doctor who reviews yeah I
didn't bust out the all the stuff today
it's hot at the time that I'm recording
this one so forgive me for not busting
out the leather in any case today gonna
take a look at Doctor Who's first
two-parter of the modern era which was
aliens of London and World War three so
it is the Slitheen storyline and this
story is such a pain for me to watch
because it has unabashedly some of my
favorite Eccleston moments and scenes he
is so on here he's got fantastic
delivery on some great lines I love that
every step of the way early on when this
thing crashes he just standing there
with this huge grin on his face like oh
let's go check it out and I love his
excitement but I love how he gets darker
and more serious and again we're seeing
the impacts of the damage that he's
carrying just in these quiet moments
where he's just looking at the phone as
Jackie's say hey can you promise me my
daughter will never get hurt and he
doesn't answer cuz he can't there's no
answer he can give to that he's plays
this so wonderfully like I knew
Eccleston was good I always knew my
customers good I think it's been too
long since I've revisited the series I
forget how good he was he's so he's
awesome he's so awesome like I said some
of my favorite moments I love the
narrows it down thing I love that whole
sequence I love that when the little pig
alien runs down a hall screaming is shot
by a soldier he chastised the soldier
what did you do that for it was scared
I loved how
genuinely upset he is it's moments like
that that Eccleston has that I think I I
don't mean to bang on this ahead of
schedule but you know when I say tenant
belt
feels too human for my liking it's
lacked it's a lack of moments like these
that makes tenant feel more human than I
like the doctor it's those moments that
immediately remind us that he is not one
of us and it's played really really well
and plus we get the introduction of
Harriet Jones who is a character I love
and she's great here right off the bat
just all the more reason for me to feel
like she got done wrong by the doctor
and possibly by the show later on but
again getting ahead of myself and roses
fine Micky does decently I did forget
how much of a jerk the doctor was to
Mickey though I would say unjustifiably
like the the degree to which he hammers
that Mickey is in excess I would say
it's nice that he kind of gets over that
by the end but it's it's a little much
and before I get to my complaints about
them the Slitheen when portrayed by the
human actors are actually quite well
performed they have a sense of menace
and threat to them so all those actors
you know the standing Prime Minister
blon fel fotch slowly and the one who
will see again later on the the general
they all do actually pretty dang good
work and the Slitheen costumes are
actually fairly impressive all things
considered the practical costumes are
but yeah so let's deal with the elephant
in the room first the farting it is so
unnecessary and yes I get that it is
slightly deeper than oh hey they farted
because you know Oh politicians are gas
bags get it yeah I get
it's still not funny and it just keeps
doing it over and over and over
especially you know that that first
thing booked before we see the month up
to hem for the first time it just drags
and so much farting oh god so that
stuff's really painful well I think the
execution of the look of the Slovene or
the execution of the you know full
costumes is pretty impressive the design
not so much the baby-faced thing is
weird and off-putting in a way that
doesn't work in this case I think having
an off-putting alien can work wonders
when your story is benefits from that
this this is a case where it's
off-putting in a way that doesn't work
because these these villains are being
played for comedy about half the time we
see them so going for that kind of
off-putting doesn't quite play at least
I don't think it does and then we've got
Oh Jackie the doctor doesn't like Jackie
either but at least unlike Mickey I get
why he doesn't like her right off the
bat and the whole thing with the doctor
says he got her back in twelve hours and
instead it's been 12 months ultimately I
don't really understand what purpose
that served it serves a very convoluted
narrative purpose because it means that
eventually Jackie will like follow them
and realize that something's up with the
doctor and call it in and the doctor
gets brought in because Jackie called it
in but first of all there had to be a
way less convoluted way to get the
doctor to 10 Downing Street because he
was spotted you know you just could have
had somebody spot them but the TARDIS
for crying out loud you could have done
that or I mean you can have Jackie find
out you know or a suspect that the
doctor is an alien without having
do this whole Rose has been gone for a
year thing because ultimately that has
no consequences and no impact whatsoever
it doesn't even establish that the
doctor isn't as good at piloting the
TARDIS as he probably should be we
actually established that last episode
because he tried to land in 1760 and
landed in 1769 or was in 1860 or
whatever he was off by nine years when
when I when he landed in the unquiet
dead and he didn't land in the city he
thought he landed in so we already know
he can be often that so that's not new
information and then putting these
characters through an emotional wringer
for what why what is the point about
besides drama and I don't like that kind
of forced familial drama it's one of the
staples of Davies Azera that I really
don't care for and this is one of the
more egregious and needless and
crowbarred in examples of that happening
so I don't really care for much of that
there's a lot of things that I can
nitpick at it as well like like I know
this one might be weird but I feel like
I've never seen anybody bring this up
before so Mickey is hacking into you
know this big important like UN website
under the guidance of the doctor so I'm
not questioning Mickey be able to get in
when the doctors guiding him in but the
password to get in is Buffalo misspelled
that's the password for everything why I
I spent a long time trying to figure out
is that a callback that I don't get
because even if it is that's dumb like
the idea that there is a past
word that bypasses everything on what it
should theoretically be one of the most
secure websites in the world and that
it's a password that friggin stupid and
what is that that's really that's really
stupid that's really dumb and there's
other things like like that you know
across the episode just little tiny
things that just don't make any freaking
sense
so another thing and the the next thing
I'm about to complain about this is by
no means unique to Doctor Who or
probably even this episode this happens
in a horror and sci-fi and all the time
but when human beings start unzipping
their heads nobody runs nobody does
anything except just stand there and
stare and yes I could buy the argument
while they're in shock for a certain
number of people but like they do this
and it takes like a solid minute in
front of the doctor in front of Jackie
in front of this entire room of unit and
alien people who just sit there and
stare you told me there's not one person
in that room for as long as it takes
them to do that because then he starts
unzipping his head and blue light comes
out there's nobody who goes no and just
bolts cuz that's what I would do like I
understand this is like weird and
bizarre like I kind of wonder what's
going on but like no hmm so that's how
long and drawn-out that is is dumb and
annoying so like I said it is such a
push and pull because the stuff that's
good and here is great the doctor is
great Harriet Jones is great
roses fine she's not bad she's just not
particularly remarkable in this one but
this there's so many good moments and
good instances especially for the doctor
and then there's the farting and the
stupid plotting and
these weird little things is just lazy
writing and I don't get it
it's just such a it's such an unbalanced
blend of elements you know the the
nothing nothing comes together smoothly
what's good stands on its own as great
and what is bad stands on its own as a
complete another slog so those are my
thoughts on this first two-parter what
do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff to do there are
buttons and also links down there
including to my patreon mmm yeah maybe
it's a thought there down there if you
want to check about there's other links
that take you other places click on some
of them could be fun so um that's gonna
wrap up this one folks you remember you
are the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is a
jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]